Nous compatissons avec celui qui nous explique se sentir bien petit,
mais nous ne faisons pas le lien avec la discrimination.
Les histoires les plus importantes, surtout en terme de justice sociale,
sont celles qui regroupent
un témoignage personnel mais aussi la possibilité
d'explorer et de comprendre le contexte politique.
Ce ne sont pas les histoires qu'on aime
contre celles qu'on préfère ignorer.
Nous vivons de plus en plus dans une société
où les forces en jeu sont nombreuses,
où pour beaucoup, les histoires remplacent les actualités.
Non ?
Nous vivons à une époque où les faits importent moins,
les émotions prévalent,
et l'analyse, c'est ennuyant, non ?
Nous préférons nos sentiments à nos connaissances.
Une étude récente du Pew Center
sur les tendances américaines
montre que seulement 10% des adultes de moins de 30 ans
« font confiance aux médias ».
C'est très significatif.
Cela prouve que la confiance dans les témoignages
augmente autant que diminue
la confiance dans les médias.
Ce qui n'est pas une bonne chose
car même si les témoignages sont importants
et nous donnent des renseignements utiles,
nous avons besoin des médias.
De mes années en tant qu'activiste en justice sociale,
je sais que nous avons besoin de faits avérés
rapportés par les institutions médiatiques
et confortés par des témoignages forts.
C'est ce qui peut jouer en faveur de la justice sociale.
Pour conclure cette analyse, bien sûr,
c'est la justice
qui rend le monde meilleur,
pas les histoires, non ?
Et donc, si ce que nous réclamons, c'est plus de justice,
nous ne devrions pas nous concentrer
sur les médias ou les témoignages.
Nous devons privilégier le public,
toute personne qui a allumé sa radio
ou écouté un podcast
ce qui veut dire nous tous.
Alors, voilà mes dernières réflexions
sur comment le public peut rendre le monde meilleur.
Tout d'abord, le monde serait meilleur, je pense,
si le public était plus curieux et plus sceptique
et posait plus de questions sur le contexte social
à la base de ces histoires que nous aimons tant.
Ensuite, le monde serait meilleur
si le public comprenait
que raconter une histoire est un travail intellectuel.
Et je pense que le public devrait
exiger plus de boutons sur ses sites web préférés,
des boutons comme,
« Si vous aimez cette histoire,
Cliquez ici pour soutenir une cause chère au narrateur que vous aimez. »
ou « Cliquez ici pour contribuer à sa prochaine grande idée. »
Souvent, on se concentre sur les plateformes
et pas toujours sur les narrateurs eux-mêmes.
Enfin, je pense que le public peut rendre le monde meilleur
en éteignant les téléphones,
en s'éloignant des écrans,
en reprenant pied dans la vraie vie, au-delà de leur bulle de sécurité.
Alice Walker a dit :
« Regardez bien le présent que vous êtes en train de construire,
il devrait ressembler au futur dont vous rêvez. »
Les narrateurs peuvent nous aider à rêver,
mais c'est à nous tous d'avoir un plan d'action en faveur de la justice.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)